all right we are live at natcon senator
ted cruz just spoke in the main room
we're out in the conference hallway over
here and i have douglas murray we're
going to count this as a reuben report
appearance which makes this your
672nd
appearance on the rumor report i think
you may have overtaken gad sad as of
today oh wow he'll be livid yeah
not be happy about it how you doing man
i'm good yeah yeah you are here in
america these days i am i am how do you
make this what do you make of this crazy
place uh well we're in orlando florida
at the moment and as people watching
will know i mean it's a different state
of state which i think is one of the
great advantages of this country i mean
at least you don't have this sort of
completely monolithic arrangements with
covid or anything else you know people
can
pretty much choose where they want to be
and what they want to put up with so do
you really sense that here i mean as
someone from the uk where now you're in
new york a lot but we're here in florida
i've seen you in l.a and you've bounced
around the country how different it is
and how good that is versus because i
don't think americans realize it's not
like that in other countries yeah i mean
it's
that's right
in a country like my own country the
united kingdom uh it's
the same rule
with some regional differences the
regional differences tend to be to
compete with each other to be even more
hardcore with the regulations around
kobet
but
if you're in most countries across
europe you know you you have one set of
rules you've got to obey them across the
country
same in australia same new zealand
i like the flexibility in america i
think it's one of the geniuses of the
founding of this country that you have
that flexibility within the nation how
do you feel as a guy that basically has
predicted all of this i mean if we were
to look at
certainly madness and crowds but all of
your writing over the last however many
years and from as long as i've known you
for about five years i mean you've been
saying this stuff is coming you've been
saying the barbarians are at the gate
and as i always quote you we're going to
be debating what gender pronouns to call
them um
like is it going to get much worse if
you're in the prediction game
i mean i don't like to think i am in the
prediction game because predictions are
for fools because i mean but you've got
a pretty good track record well i never
i never talked about pandemics
i never wrote about pandemics i mean i
think that's a
failing
because obviously it was something we
should have thought about more i always
thought of it as one of those sessions
in conferences about security issues
which one ducked out of
that's for the crazy people yeah
well that's one of the ones you can miss
uh i mean
it was for a small number of of people
it was their thing
their thing turns out to have come
around
uh so i i never particularly thought
about that and uh in a way i mean i've
i've avoided a lot of the covert
discussion in the last uh 18 months
because
i don't like to throw myself into issues
that i haven't thought about deeply
already and
but i mean you're writing that some of
the things i've written about
immigration the worker arty the
crowd stampedes on social issues and
others they have got a lot worse since i
wrote about them
i don't always contribute
you know endlessly to those debates
because i try to sort of say my piece
and
and then leave the leave a field in a
way in the hope that other people come
in and they have i mean i i'm
i'm much enthused by the way in which
now lots of people have picked up some
of the issues i've written about
i don't know if that means they get
better but there's certainly more people
in the fight and that's a good thing do
you sense things might turn around kind
of soon like i think this election
tomorrow in virginia is key although
it's ironic because as a californian at
least for now i shouldn't really care
about a virginian election yeah as
someone from the uk you shouldn't really
care about a a virginian gubernatorial
election and yet here we are
well there's a reason for that isn't
there which is i mean if we were in
a suburb of athens at the moment
discussing athenian politics
would be
interesting maybe gossip worthy quite
possibly but
essentially apologies to any greeks
watching essentially unimportant
that's not the case in the united states
of america uh um the reason why every
inch of land is fought over politically
so hard is because every inch of land
does matter
and that's because this is the still
point of the turning world i mean this
is the place
where if you get it wrong
the whole next century goes wrong if you
get it right the next century can go
better i mean that's why it's important
to be in the united states that's why
it's important to fight every every inch
of
the terrain
what happens here will affect everywhere
we were discussing this over dinner last
night but do you think any of the
institutions now can be saved or do you
think the ship has sailed sort of across
the board no i'm sure they can be i mean
uh yeah part of what we were discussing
i wrote about this recently the
spectator is that i am very struck being
an american by the way in which
conservatives in particular have really
turned on the institutions now there is
a good reason for that i think the
people who run
i mean well let me just write back like
five years ago we might have talked
about for instance the corruption of the
media the mainstream media
uh um
that's been the discussion in america
for
more than 20 years i mean uh
um
biased was out 20 years ago
culture and others writing about this 15
years ago the media thing was sort of a
familiar issue you might say the same
thing about american universities
but this is an old discussion by now i
mean you know alan bloomberg the closing
of the american mind uh which exposed
the problems in american universities in
the 1980s right
people born long after that now in
political sentience
you know who know this is the issue that
that's not that's not new it's it's
really old hat now yeah i'm worried
about the fact that not much has been
done about either of these things
although something's been done about the
media right but
more striking to me is the way in which
yes the institutions have been hollowed
out and turned against in a different
way uh
it's very worrying to me that for
instance we see this uh wholesale
dislike of for instance the top brass of
the american military
now there's good reason for that not
just national security failures but
general mili and others talking about
critical race theory whilst they lose
afghanistan
they've made themselves sort of uh not
just dismissible figures but uh
unlikable figures and indeed deridable
figures that's very very dangerous much
worse is the same thing happening with
the nsa the cia the fbi
uh effectively the infrastructure of the
security infrastructure of a country
that is
that is new that conservatives have
turned on that and i say there's good
reason for them to have turned on that
but it's very very worrying and i would
urge people not to throw out the whole
thing i i think it's
i think you basically don't have a
conservative movement if you believe
that every single institution in the
country is so rotten
uh that you've got to chug it out
because that's not what you were saying
you were saying last night that in
effect it would be hard for you to
imagine this happening in the uk where
people would be openly sort of against
mi6 or something like that you're not
saying there isn't good reason for it
but it's like i guess the question is
how do we mitigate the craziness and
still not burn down those institutions
that's right i mean
yeah the example i was giving over
dinner was uh you couldn't have a
conservative movement in the uk or
anything like it that believed that the
top of the military were all corrupt and
ridiculous
that mi5 mi6 and
gthq were all basically corrupted
institutions you could never consider
the uk who also believed that the
electoral institutions were wholly
corrupted the judiciary was corrupted
and so on and so i mean what exactly at
that point do you conserve it
and there's this additional there which
i think i mentioned which is in america
is in this particularly powerless
position because you know take a country
like france uh uh
there are many disputes going on
in particular the moment within france
and many interesting contests going on
but
the french do not believe that the k dos
say is against france
whereas you know there is a very
significant swathe now populist ways of
american public opinion an opinion on
the american right that believes that
you know the state department is not on
your side uh this is a very very hard
thing to
roll back from i do think it's
salvageable but my god a lot of work
needs to be put in and that's going to
have to be much harder work than the
trump administration era willing to put
in you know a lot of what i think
happened in the trump years was you had
this sort of critique from the top and
nothing happened you know the the
institutions just continued doing their
thing there wasn't the interest in the
minutiae and getting people in at the
right level
uh anything like it there was a sort of
it was like uh doing up the penthouse
whilst the whole rest of the building
was rotten yeah if if you go along with
that critique that i've just
outline
no it's it's going to be work to not
burn them down yet also understand that
something is something is wrong yeah i
mean you can't
realistically just
tear everything down and rebuild
from the ground up uh you can't do it
with platitudes or with
you know uh incendiary comments you you
you you'd have to put in the work
is there a movement willing to do that
possibly it's in it's very nascent
movements in the meantime you've got to
reform the institutions you have but
that is a very
unappealing prospect for most people
right it's a lot of work it might be
happening a little bit right here right
now that's what a lot is about now that
we have a big crowd out here since the
uh
the conference just let out give me one
i thought it was because we were talking
and it's definitely because we're here
talking about this stuff give me your
final one minute classic douglas douglas
murray what's going on in the world
[Laughter]
you always end all of these just on that
perfect note now i'm really handing it
to you i have a colleague in the in this
potato in london who writes our lowlife
column uh called jeremy clark some years
ago said to me or something he said he's
at a great east east center he said you
seem to be somebody who knows what's
going on douglas i said it was very kind
he said so what's going on
i said you're gonna have to narrow that
question you're gonna have to narrow
that question a bit i think i'd say the
same with you uh
i will accept i will accept that as the
answer uh it's it's
there's so much going on yeah dick in
america
uh
i i think that people have got to
tend to their
backyard tend to their own garden tend
to the patch around them a lot better
i think we see that in america i i don't
know the reason i'm unusually optimistic
about the situation in america
is that actually you do have movements
of people here who want to tend to the
thing in front of them and around them
uh you see this thing with
parents applying for roles i'm told
they're like school boards that don't
exist sometimes i mean they just there's
so much desire to
get involved and to turn around some of
the great particularly things like the
crt craziness there's a lot of will in
in the public in america to get involved
and that's the solution and that's the
solution is you know very few people can
affect uh the politics of the highest
level
make much difference change about the
local governor or let alone the
president but they can do something
about the patch right around them
there's a willingness in america to do
that that's why i'm you find me in in
america unusually optimistic yeah and we
just like hearing these things from a
brit frankly
you always sound
like you know what you're talking about
well i don't know i mean the thing about
that's not just the sound
ah there you go all right we're going to
swap mike's i'm going to bring in chris
roofo
great pleasure as always all right all
right if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell